JOEL MCKELVEY: Hello,
and welcome to Looker
and BigQuery--
Enterprise Digital
Transformation at Sunrun.
I'm Joel Mckelvey with the
Looker team, and joining me
is Harish Ramachandraiah
from Sunrun.
We're going to be talking
about modernizing your data
infrastructure and modernizing
your analytics together
to drive better
business outcomes
and to accelerate
digital transformation
in your organization.
Now, this is particularly
important now,
because we know that data-driven
or insight-driven businesses
are far more likely to succeed
during a time of disruption
like the one we're seeing now.
They're going to
be more profitable,
have higher customer
satisfaction and customer
retention, and
they're going to be
able to drive better
and more efficient
operations, et cetera.
So it's really key that we
be successful with data.
So then why are more companies
not successful with data?
And I think it comes down
to-- with all the businesses
I've spoken with--
this concern of balancing
the maintenance,
keeping the lights on,
using the systems that
exist already with the need to
innovate, and update, and build
new systems or better
systems going forward.
And it comes down to a rapidly
increasing supply of the three
Vs of volume, variety,
and velocity of data,
but also, an incredible
demand for data and demand
for insights in the business.
And keeping up with the
two of those, particularly
when you're maintaining
legacy systems,
can be a real challenge.
Good news is that there's hope.
With modern technology, data
lakes and data warehouses
have effectively
become a single entity.
That is to say, the massively
parallel processing,
cloud-based database
like BigQuery
can be both a data lake
and a data warehouse.
So you no longer need a staging
database, an analytic database,
and maybe a data mart.
All that data can
be consolidated
in a single location,
which gives you
a really nice source of
truth for the business,
simplifying data pipelines,
making analytics much more
real time.
And then when you take a modern
analytics system like Looker
and you connect it to one of
these modern data warehouses,
suddenly you've got data
governance at scale.
Data becomes very,
very accessible.
You free up your
data teams to do more
and to focus more
on that innovation.
And you can operationalize data
in new and very exciting ways
to drive those
outcomes you need.
What we call these
new ways of using data
is "data experiences."
Certainly, all the
organizations I work with
are looking at modernizing
business intelligence-- getting
better dashboards and
reporting, making that simpler,
making that easier.
But there are new
ways to use data
when you're not spending all of
your time on the infrastructure
and analytics maintenance.
And these new ways
include putting analytics
directly in the CRM
or a chat application
that your teams might be using,
inserting insights directly
into people's workflows,
right where and when they
need the most to make
better decisions-- not just
large-scale decisions
in the organization,
but even microscale
decisions, say,
on a factory production line
or something along those lines,
so making data so
operationalized
that the people consume it may
not even know that what they're
seeing is analytics outcome.
And you can even build custom
applications or use data
in really new, interesting,
and innovative ways
to monetize data or drive those
outcomes you're looking for.
So one organization that's
been very successful
driving positive business
outcomes with data
is Sunrun, led by
Harish Ramachandraiah,
who's with me today.
And he's going to talk a
little bit about his transition
from an older
infrastructure to where
he is today, some of the
pitfalls and benefits he's
seen doing that.
And I think you'll be
really excited to hear
what he has to say.
So with that, I'm going
to hand over to Harish.
Harish, take it away.
HARISH RAMACHANDRAIAH:
Thank you, Joel.
Thanks.
So with that said, just a
quick background about Sunrun.
Sunrun has been in the
solar industry, number
one residential solar company.
It's pioneered in the solar
industry for quite some time
now.
And since then, it has
offered a number of products
out there, the
latest being battery
as a service as well
as storage options.
And just to keep it simple,
what we do is essentially
have the customers
or the consumer
buy electricity at a discounted
price than what the utilities
would otherwise offer.
But what we offer
is a clean energy,
environmentally-friendly,
eco-friendly options.
And so that's our mission.
And if you look
at our mission is
to ensure that we run
the planet by the sun.
So with that said,
you could envision
any of your company
in similar profile
to the company where
you've been associated.
You may be in the crossroads
of a BI transformation,
and Sunrun was no different
a couple of years back.
So you could imagine, most
of the companies out there
either have a monolithic
transactional system, either
an SAP or an Oracle
environment, and then
a number of other platforms
in terms of marketing or sales
platforms.
And counter to that, you
have BI applications,
where you essentially
have locked
into a license, or an
infrastructure, or a support
cost, and skill sets,
and so on and so forth.
And we were no
different than that.
Along with that, I think some
of the business questions-- what
we were trying to address in
terms of the transformation
was, how do I justify the ROI?
Or how do I do the
transformation yet
without doing the
disruption in the existing
side of the business?
And within the
engineering team, we
were in the dilemma
trying to figure out
that it isn't as simple as a
lift-and-shift of your data
sets, all the schemas,
from one environment
to the other environment,
or importing these pipelines
from one to the other ecosystem.
And are you really going
to solve the problem?
And certainly not.
You want to take advantage
of the newer platforms
with the better architecture,
and so on, so forth.
So how did we solve that?
So we embarked on a journey
two to three years back
in trying to figure
out, how do we
go about transforming
some of these problems?
And some of the critical
ones I have noted here,
but I'm sure most of you can
relate to this, as well as it
resonates among you--
is time to market.
From a business standpoint,
it was very, very critical
for us to work in close
proximity with the business
to be able to turn around
some of their analytical needs
in a very short duration.
And given the situation,
the expectations
was to build, deploy,
and be able to execute
some of these products
in a very short duration.
And given that we were
operating in a capital-
and labor-intensive market,
it was very critical
for us to be able to turn
around some of these things.
Also, the most popular one
about single source of truth--
given the number of
integration points
we have, each of
the business units
would have their own set
of single source of truth,
or their own versions of it,
and then the timings of it,
which would never align
and they would never
come to an agreement.
And so we wanted to
take this opportunity
to ensure that some of
those business rules
are encapsulated, both at
the physical layer as well
as the logical layer
for the senior execs
to come into the forum
and be able to align,
based on the KPI of the
same set of metrics, what
they would have agreed upon.
And so it was very
prudent for us
to ensure that that
single source of truth
is in good shape, and further
to that, as the infrastructure.
And for those of us who've
come in from the legacy
platform or the on-premise side
of it, having a managed service
was the best thing to
have, or-- we love it.
Considering that you're
looking at the pipelines,
you're looking at the
infrastructure from a data
warehousing standpoint-- just
data sets at a petabyte scale--
as well as from a
reporting standpoint,
where you [? only ?]
have certain expectations
to scale up the number of
users, and so on and so forth.
And we certainly were--
we didn't want to be in the
business of capacity planning.
And so that was very
important for us
to be able to autoscale
some of these expectations.
The other thing was in terms
of the cost aspects of it.
And for us, it
certainly mattered
to figure out, what are
the kind of transaction
some of these projects
are undertaking?
And what are the
costs involved in it?
Are we locked in?
Is it flexible enough?
Can we predict some of
these cost aspects of it?
So that tomorrow,
if the business
needs to do
additional investment,
they have full transparency
about what it is costing us.
And that level of visibility,
certainly, would be helping us.
And finally, the
most important one
is certainly the security and
the compliance side of it,
which is-- we handle
quite a bit of it.
There is still a lot to go
there in terms of the DLP,
in terms of PIA.
And in the next
subsequent quarters,
we certainly plan
to address that.
So with that said,
I would not go
into the legacy
aspects of it, but more
on the current infrastructure
or the architecture, what
we have in place at Sunrun.
So if you look at this, you're
looking from left to right.
And essentially, you
have a combination
of various platform on cloud,
on-premise, as well as formats
of these data sets
in terms of CSV
to API to JSON, all
kinds of format.
At the same time, you're
looking at the data
coming from some of these
financial systems like Oracle.
We have two ERP environments,
and Workday production data
sets coming from solar panels,
and so on and so forth.
And some of these
data sets certainly
have highly time-sensitive from
a investor relationship or Wall
Street information, as well
as Workday, for example,
as a number of footprints in
terms of productivity, and as
well as traditional reporting,
and so on and so forth.
So as this data makes its way
into the target environment,
which is the cloud storage where
we retain the raw form of it,
we use a number of components
or variations of this
in terms of Dataproc,
Dataflow, and then informatics
are predominantly placed in
terms of doing the pipeline.
And so the rough form which
arrives at the cloud storage
is almost like an
audit trail coming out
of the source system.
You could trace back any of
this transaction information.
But subsequent to that
is where we kind of take
a two-step approach in
terms of staging the data
and then subsequently
the live table.
Between the two steps,
what we essentially do
is to ensure that
the change data
capture gets handled in a very
seamless manner in stage one.
And then subsequently, if there
are any heavy transformation
of the business rules,
we incorporate it
in the subsequent
step, which is probably
close to 20% of those
elements get transformed.
But by and large, we take
advantage of the staging
itself from a
reporting standpoint.
And so between
the two, we ensure
that we are good to go from
a reporting standpoint,
from a physical layer, and start
building the logical layer.
And along the way,
we also ensure
that we make the best practice
from a BigQuery standpoint,
whether it's in terms of
[? updation, ?] making sure
that it is cost effective,
as well as establishing
certain joins.
Because just in the nature
of BigQuery, in terms of this
being a distributed
system, we want
to make sure it makes really
sense where it needs to join.
If not, we try to take
advantage of the platform.
And then we have
certain homegrown,
open-source
orchestration engine.
And then we have
scheduler from the Airflow
and other monitoring
tools in order
to maintain, manage
these pipelines.
And subsequently,
it makes its way
from a consumer
standpoint, where
we have Looker, which is our
prominent reporting tool,
not just from the visualization
and report aspects,
but also, we take
advantage of it
in more like a
data as a service.
And that is something which we
are in full thrust as we speak.
Besides Looker,
where I think close
to 70-odd percent
of the execs rely
on some of these
reporting aspects
coming out of the Looker,
there are other consumers.
There are some cases where
Google Studio makes use of it
for quick turnarounds, and
POCs, and so on and so forth.
The EAI and ML people, again,
tap into the same data sets.
And for them, it is
a curated data sets.
It is transformed.
There's nothing much they need
to do versus focus on modeling
and take full advantage of
what BigQuery can provide them
from an EAI and ML standpoint.
And then the other
consumers are your--
and some of the
planning systems,
as well as we also provide
the integration hub.
So that's how the current
structure, but if you really
look at, there are a number
of pipes or the arrow marks,
which essentially,
they are equally
prone for certain failures.
And so we ensure that these
are well managed, monitored,
and taken care.
And to give you a quick preview
of the pipelines, the data
warehouse, I'll just
quickly go over that.
So as I pointed out in
terms of the double click,
any failure in these pipelines
can cost a wrong decision
downstream.
So we want to make sure
that it is well managed.
And so the footprint is closer
around 700-odd pipelines
as we speak.
And it is growing incrementally
almost every month.
The other aspect of this is the
type of transactions we handle.
It's not just the
volume side of it.
It's more to do
with the complexity
across the various data
sources as well as correlations
of these data sets.
In order to write a good data
story for some of the business
units, you're talking
of integrations
between financial systems,
Salesforce systems,
as well as [INAUDIBLE]
and so on and so forth
to do some complex analysis from
a cycle time from conversion
analysis, as well as
the reporting coming out
of the tax and
financial systems.
Besides that, we started
at the cadence of 24 hours
in terms of scheduling
these data sets.
That's got reduced almost
to an hour every day.
And so we run these jobs
at a very high frequency
on most of the
environments, including ERP.
Then just to double click
on the BigQuery again,
this is more to talk about
how we manage these slot
allocations from a
resource standpoint.
Essentially, we have
three segments here--
the ETL, or in our case,
we manage the ELT process,
Looker from a
reporting standpoint,
and then the back-end users
who tap into the BigQuery.
These are the three segments.
But we also have the
ability to prioritize.
And, in our case, we have Looker
as the most prominent end-user
community to take
advantage of it.
And then the other
slots come into picture.
So that's the brief approach.
And so far, we haven't
had any challenges
in terms of resource allocation.
And if you have to scale up,
it's a matter of a few minutes.
You can certainly
scale up even further.
So that's the aspects from a
data warehousing standpoint,
and then, finally,
the reporting.
Looker, again, has
come a long way for us.
And so, as I said,
it is not just
reporting in terms of
visualization aspects.
We've taken it in terms of
the hub-and-spoke models
within the Looker community,
where we not only enable
the business users to do
self-service reports, not just
the canned or building
those reports.
But also, if you really
look at the power users,
we extend our capacity
of development effort
along with the
business community
in terms of enabling
the data models
as well as exploring
it and establishing
certain metrics which the
central engineering team may
or may not necessarily address.
But instead, we
have an opportunity
to extend those spoke models
into the business community.
So overall, that has accelerated
not only the development cycle
but also to bring in some
of the assembly knowledge
which the business units
can bring in and turn
around certain POCs, integrate
some of their data sets, which
we probably don't
have as Workday,
and have a wider footprint,
and have a protocol to ensure,
besides some of the automation
in terms of testing these data
sets, [? CSEd ?] processing,
and so on and so forth.
So that's on the reporting side.
And just to take
it further, I just
wanted to highlight one
of the case studies.
I know there are a
lot of information
about the social media analytics
in terms of sales conversions,
of marketing channels
analysis out there.
And so we thought of sharing
some of the case studies
from an Oracle
financial standpoint,
where we were having a pre-built
ETL, or a pipeline, as well
as physical data models,
[? Starsky ?] models,
as well as a report
coming out of the box,
and something which we
engineered within the Google
platform to ensure that some
of these data sets-- you know,
there are hundreds of
these pipelines, which
are fairly complex in nature.
As I said, it's not
just the volume.
It is the complexity in
integrating various data sets.
And in this example,
the financials
in terms of general ledger,
accounts receivables, payables,
we take advantage of it in
order to arrive at the profit
and loss statements.
And it has been engineered
from the ground up at Sunrun.
The other aspects which
you can even take it
further is you could
easily integrate this
into a demand planning
system along with it,
as well as a financial
planning system.
And there are other aspects.
If you're running a
marketing campaign
during a certain
period, you could
snapshot those
information real time
and be able to see if
these are having an impact.
Your campaigns, are they having
impact from the dollar aspects,
in terms of conversions?
And look at it within
a particular window.
We haven't certainly
done it, but since we've
taken care of the
financial system,
it's easily imaginable
to integrate
some of these data sets.
And we have converted the entire
financial systems, as well as
some of the other supply
chain, and so on and so forth
on the Oracle financials.
And you can easily have laid
this to an [? exterior ?]
environment, where you
are handling controlling
and profitability, or
a [? low ?] cockpits,
[? MLS, ?] and so
on and so forth.
So with that said, I just
wanted to quickly go over
the certain monitoring aspects
on each of those environments.
We have the ability
to manage and monitor
the GCP environment, the Looker,
as well as load orchestration.
And in these other reports,
which we use out of Looker
to ensure that there is
consistency in the data loops,
if there are any failures
or any exceptions, alerts,
we have automation done in place
to handle on a overnight basis,
and not necessarily
lose sleep over it.
And there's more to go, but
this is something which we
handle on a day-to-day basis.
And then one quick
question on areas
in terms of establishing that
confidence within the business
community was pretty
critical for us.
And so we put a lot of things
in place, or process in place
to ensure that the
business are looking
at the very authoritative data.
And the [? slates ?]
essentially speaks
about how the weak
insulation happens
between the source system
and the target environment.
In this case, the
production, if you notice,
is in a fairly good shape.
We run this process
along with the data loads
to ensure that the
number of transaction
or any impacts on the
metadata structures
or any elements being
introduced is reconciling
between source and the targets.
And as you can see,
the QA is suddenly
out of sync, and essentially
because there are no projects.
[INAUDIBLE] projects
in the current state,
as well as on the
dev environments,
where work is in progress.
So these are some
of the things which
helps establish those confidence
within the business units
to take it further.
And just to give you just about
the journey where we started,
we started something
like a phase
zero where we
undertook our POC--
and it was certainly
not a lift-and-shift--
engaged with a
number of partners,
and then embarked on a
full-scale development effort.
And we took approximately a year
and a half to cover 80% to 90%
of the footprint from our
legacy platform into the cloud.
And we basically undertook
certain user community,
which would gain more
mileage, and took
advantage of the
platform, and certainly
build those confidence.
And then it was kind of
wildfire at Sunrun to enable
some of the business units.
And that came extremely handy.
And there was a lot of
acknowledgment in Sunrun.
And certainly, today, most
of the core reporting aspects
comes out of GCP and Looker.
And we wrapped up our project
100% into the cloud now.
It's been a couple of quarters
since we've gone live.
And currently, we are heading
more towards the ML and EAI
initiatives, taking advantage of
what the BigQuery platform can
provide us in addition
to the analytics.
And just a final thought
as the takeaway--
this is the final
point what we got out
of our overall initiative
was how could we
add business value back into--
and there's this particular
slide, if you really
notice our legacy
infrastructure,
or the legacy environment,
and the application
in terms of the dev cycle,
what it would undertake
was essentially, we
reduced significantly
in terms of your
infrastructure as well as
data modeling aspects and
the reporting enablement.
And we've reduced in
some of the areas close
to 70%, 80% in
terms of lifecycle.
And certainly, those are
the business benefits
which we can give it back.
And it has certainly
increased our footprint.
And it's been an extremely
successful run at Sunrun.
And both with great partnership
with Looker and BigQuery,
we were able to achieve this
in a very short duration.
I just wanted to thank my
team, BI team at Sunrun,
and certainly my
boss, [? Loren, ?]
for providing the support.
He [? hatched ?] the engineering
team, and before him,
we wouldn't have been here.
And so thank you all.
And I hope you
have some takeaway
from these initiatives, both
from a Looker and a BigQuery
standpoint.
And I'll be certainly here
to field any questions
and answers.
Thank you.